this video is brought to you by warby
parker
what's up wisecrack i don't know if
you've heard but there's a group of
people that pretty much
the whole world seems to hate right now
whether it's america's least favorite
sunscreen enthusiast self-appointed
health czar
lex luthor impersonator hair transplant
aficionado or
teary-eyed hedge fund manager i care
people across the political spectrum are
pissed that some folks have made
bank off the recent economic crisis now
we all know that america's filthy rich
have gotten filthier and
richer in recent years while the rest of
us are trying to make family size boxes
powdered mac and cheese last a whole
week
you can save on your water bill if you
just eat it dry still
most of us have been taught to see this
as just a fact of life a natural
extension of the free market
but having massive wealth in the hands
of a few tech bros wasn't necessarily
preordained
we'll explain in this wisecrack edition
on billionaires what went
wrong and before we get into it i want
to give a shout out to this week's
sponsor
warby parker warby parker provides
boutique quality eyewear for a great
value they're committed to providing
exceptional vision care online and in
stores they offer eyeglasses sunglasses
eye exams and contact lenses with warby
parker you can finally get sunglasses
progressives and blue light lenses that
are built with your script their glasses
start at 95 dollars
including prescription lenses if you're
interested but don't see yourself
heading to the store anytime soon
you can order frames from the comfort of
your couch with their free home try on
program you can get
five frames shipped to your house so you
can see what works best for you
if you don't have any idea of where to
start they have a quick quiz to help you
decide whether you need wide frames or
what styles might look best for your
face shape
it only took me two minutes and i got my
frames pretty soon after i loved that i
had the chance to try them on
take a few pics and ask my roommate what
they thought before i sent them back to
make my decision
of course the best part is that there is
no obligation to buy in case you don't
find your perfect frame so try warby
parker's free home try on program
order five pairs of glasses to try at
home for free for five days
there is no obligation to buy and it
ships for free with a prepaid return
shipping label
try five pairs of glasses at home for
free by going to warbyparker.com
wisecrack now back to the show today
having billionaires seems as natural as
eating a hot dog encased in a thick
layer of deep-fried cornmeal batter but
for early americans both things would
have been unthinkable
and not just because of inflation and
high cholesterol see our 18th century
countrymen
overwhelmingly imagine themselves to be
different from britain
with its stuffy aristocracy inbred kings
and generational wealth
of course that didn't stop some early
americans from making
bank there was a fledgling aristocracy
flaunting their sick digs much of which
had been acquired in sketchy ways like
looting british ships stealing native
american landing goods slavery or just
ripping off the government's war effort
and everyone else they typically lived
in small towns running small farms or
working as
trades people or you know slavery as
historian kevin phillips notes
outside of plantations and fledgling
cities social stratification was pretty
limited
you probably weren't jealous of your
rich friend's new shoes because you each
most likely had only one pair of
homemade shoes
while this may sound devastating to
sneaker heads it also would have
prevented the pain of waking up at 7
am on multiple saturdays just to have
the sneaker zap break your heart again
so when did america's first adjusted for
inflation billionaires really emerge
post-civil war baby aka the gilded age
in good american fashion some of these
dudes initially made bank from scamming
the government
like selling uniforms during the civil
war that straight up fell to pieces in
the rain
hopefully making for some steamy moments
on the battlefield
but billionaire status was only really
possible with our first nationwide
business
railroads this new transportation
network made it possible to ship
supplies and consumer goods
across the country and the dudes who
built it like john d rockefeller and
andrew carnegie
soon became the zuckerbergs and gates's
of their time
though thankfully more stylish and much
like 70s meryl streep star power
life for the very wealthy would shoot up
drastically over just three decades by
73 of the nation's wealth would be held
by just 10 percent of the population
and they do questionable things to show
it off like build a gold toilet
or import 10 000 butterflies from brazil
for their daughter's debutante ball
side note all the butterflies died and
their corpses rained down on the
partygoers
and what could i say i would watch the
[ __ ] out of that tick tock
but our new billionaires needed a way to
justify having enough dollar bills to
wallpaper the great wall of china
because again
it was pretty new in america to have so
much money in the hands of just a few
cigar happy dudes
luckily they found a little thing called
social darwinism
this intellectual movement took darwin's
views on biological evolutionary
competition amongst natural
species and applied it very
pseudoscientifically to human society
the thinking went in a competitive
economy like on a competitive earth the
creatures arose to the top did so
because they were [ __ ] lions
who deserve success
and also golden crusted pedestals in
their drawing rooms but despite being
huge proponents of the free market the
wealthiest really relied on the
government to maintain their status as
champions of capitalism for the most
part that meant keeping government out
of their way via laissez-faire economics
because the free market equals bay this
was easy to finagle
being wealthy gave you a lot of
political sway over a congress to act
between millionaires and if you needed a
little help there was always corruption
bribery and
vote buying so for a couple decades the
government pretty much
rather than say outlawing child labor or
crafting regulations for on-the-job
safety as tens of thousands of workers
got their legs chomped by railroad
machinery and some sick industrial
version of jaws four
but billionaires were also happy for
daddy government to be hands on when it
meant
helping their bottom line that's because
federal and state governments gifted
railroad companies approximately 100
million government subsidies
and 200 million acres of public land
between 1861 and 1871 alone
it's not unlike elon musk who celebrated
as a role model for free market
innovation
will sometimes complain about excessive
regulations sometimes it can over
regulate
industries to the point where innovation
becomes very difficult
that's despite the fact that the vast
majority of tesla's profit
comes from a government mandated
regulation that makes other car
manufacturers buy carbon credits from
them anyway budding tycoons also relied
on other shady methods like manipulating
the stock market building monopolies in
order to control prices
and a whole lot of financial free so
boring i'm almost glad i'm not rich
i'm almost glad but to be fair
even some historical critics admit that
without the sheer force and breakneck
policies of these wily robber barons
america couldn't have developed as
quickly as it did which is to say
yes robber barons helped america
industrialize at lightning speed but at
the same time many of them became
well known for their philanthropy most
notably carnegie who by his
death had donated 300 million to charity
so counterpoint billionaires equal
sometimes good
to be determined the fact that some of
these guys including rockefeller and
carnegie
had worked their way up from humble
origins also made them sympathetic
success stories
many folks admired and aspired to be
like them even as their mom and pop
general stores were steamrolled by
increased corporate consolidation
spearheaded by their favorite
millionaire bros anyway the gilded age
wasn't all counting luxury imported
butterfly corpses all day to understand
how the mega wealthy fit into the social
order
we have to look at how the other 99 was
living
that's that's that's not right yeah that
see as america became the world's
leading economy
it also became a place of insane
never-before-seen
poverty people who had once survived
humbly off the land were increasingly
forced to migrate to urban slums where
they worked 14-hour days in factories
performing the exact
same task until they presumably had a
charlie chaplin-esque breakdown
okay it's a good bit but this was
seriously dangerous work
and 35 000 people died each year in
factory accidents during the 1880s and
1890s
making the average industrial job
somehow seem less safe than modern day
commercial skydiving
meanwhile by the turn of the century
elementary school for one in five
american children looked like the inside
of a factory or the pits of a coal mine
in the south small-scale farmers and
especially emancipated black folks
working as sharecroppers
suffered as farming consolidated and
land speculation ran rampant many felons
of predatory high interest debt just
trying to pay for basic necessities
and across the board volatile markets
fueled by rampant speculation amongst
the wealthy
led to regular boom and bus cycles that
made most people's experience of america
feel like the universal studios ride
dudley due rights ripsaw falls
which as we all know i'm legally banned
from attending which again is
absolutely not how america works over a
century later
dot com stocks crashed billions of
dollars in venture capital evaporated
overnight tumbled more than 500 points
after
two pillars of the street tumbled over
the weekend unemployment claims
skyrocketing with 6.6 million people
filing in the last week alone i'm just
kidding it totally does
hedge funds and the private equity firms
that she says has treated the market
like a casino anyway there's a reason
gilded age billionaires were called
robber barons a lot of poor people
really wanted to fight back
and had no access to reddit railway car
magnate george
pullman was buried in a lead-lined
coffin within a steel and concrete vault
because his family was convinced angry
workers would vandalize his grave
you thought zuckerberg memes were cruel
on a whole workers refuse to silently
accept the new realities of the gilded
age
in which millions worked punishing jobs
that collectively enriched a select
few lucky dudes that's why in the 1880s
alone there were more than 10
000 strikes many of them mass strikes
that spanned entire cities and regions
and how did the wealthy industry giants
respond with brute force of course
business owners would call in their own
private militias or even ask
uncle sam to send in troops because if
the free market means anything
it means crying to the government over
contract disputes
this wasn't just peacekeeping strikes
were often violently put down
and the national guard was called on to
respond to labor turmoil between 118 and
160 times from 1877 to 1900 alone
meanwhile over the years plenty of
well-dressed businessmen would form
armed vigilante groups to carry out
justice in the streets
conflict inevitably broke out during
working class demonstrations
like the famous astor place opera house
riot when pissed off working folks
invaded the fancy theater
throwing rotten potatoes and eggs at the
actors and shouting shame shame
down with the codfish aristocracy a
sentiment die
i personally scream into my pillow every
night before i go to bed
less humorous is the fact that at least
22 people died and over a hundred were
injured in that riot alone as a result
of the state militia's response
more explicitly labor-related kinds of
agitations lasted for decades
like in the 1920 battle of blair
mountain where thousands of coal workers
faced off against government and private
militias
in a battle that saw approximately one
million rounds of ammunition fired
and the dropping of leftover world war
one poisoned
gas and homemade bombs particularly in
the 1890s all of this violent
confrontation
gunfire and death escalated to the point
that many americans worried another
civil war was coming
still the workers persisted one 1894
strike even shut down
huge swaths of american railroad lines
costing the industry millions in losses
keep in mind folks on strike weren't
just quibbling over low wages
many wanted the entire system uprooted
suggesting radical changes like
collective ownership of company capital
and in the 1896 presidential election
william jennings bryan became the first
major political candidate to build his
brand off of working class populist rage
he was beat out when america's elite
united to throw millions behind william
mckinley's competing campaign
a lot has happened since the rise of
america's billionaire class and the
riots and strikes against them
the great depression gave way to the new
deal's civilized capitalism
and by the middle of the century it was
culturally not that cool to be super
rich
or to show off your wealth some old
money families even sold off their
ancestral homes to become orphanages or
old age homes
unions in the companies they worked for
sort of found a bit of equilibrium
union stopped agitating for the
overthrow of capitalism and businesses
started providing living wages and
substantial worker protections
wealth inequality continued to decrease
from its gilded age heights
but over the last 50 years the story has
gotten a lot more complicated
perhaps most importantly for the very
wealthy finance has increasingly become
the center of the u.s economy
now akin to what manufacturing was in
the gilded age and if national railroads
provided new opportunities for never
before seen wealth financialization is
that
but on roids thanks in part to
developments like hedge funds venture
capitalism and private equity
according to author and canadian
politician christian freeland
in the 70s finance began a
transformation from an industry
dominated by large
institutions whose job was a
conservative stewardship of other
people's money
into a sector whose moguls were
iconoclastic entrepreneurs who
specialized in risk
leverage and outsized returns at the
same time we saw an increased return to
economic laws fair policies
with the usual caveats government's
interference is welcome when it benefits
the top 1 percent's bottom line
as best exemplified by the bailout of
the big banks following the great
recession
the net result of the past five or so
decades economist simon
johnson explains that america now has
the world's most
advanced oligarchy and unlike the
railroad tycoons who were at least
producing something that helped the
lives of average americans the financial
activity generating billions for the
wealthiest today
is not accounting for 25 percent of
corporate profits
but just four percent of jobs and by
just about every metric the economy has
increasingly worked
better and better for the top one
percent today america has almost
800 billionaires what's more vast
economic wealth has become largely
self-perpetuating
as economist thomas piketty notes the
current economic climate privileges
creation of
wealth for those who already have
existing wealth at the same time
life has gotten worse for the majority
of americans in just about
every measurable way and for folks who
set out to improve
their lot well it's harder than ever
before because of a little thing called
the great gatsby curve
which is not about leonardo dicaprio's
you know
rather it's a depressing graph showing
that higher income inequality in a given
country makes it harder to rise above
your
station that's at least partly why most
young americans are worse off than their
parents for the first time in modern
history
regardless of their genius mac and
cheese cost-saving hacks
great no seriously it's it's great it
really works
none of what's happened is that
surprising over the past half century
the very wealthy have recreated the
economy in a very not fun fun house
mirror image of the gilded age
and with the 2010 citizens united
decision bringing floods of new money
into politics
economic power breeds political power
like never before
the billionarization of politics is
perhaps literalized by
self-financed political campaigns like
those of michael bloomberg
though he proved once and for all that
unlike my seventh grade nemesis chip van
der rohe of the van der rohe dynasty
once said
money can't buy popularity cute chip and
everyone that stands with van der on the
whole vander row clam cause me and the
boys are coming for you okay
but what's really most surprising to us
though is how little pushback we've seen
to this reality
as compared to the late 19th century
working-class movements the reaction to
growing wealth stratification has been
pretty anemic
sure there's outburst of rage in the
form of occupy wall street and even
aspects of the black lives matter
movement but compared to the widespread
agitation that characterized the gilded
age
it's been pretty quiet meanwhile the
remnants of social darwinism remains
strong in most ap economics classes in
spite of the fact that the very wealthy
continue to prosper off government
subsidies
there's also the continued cultural
ionization of the uber rich
particularly as with the gilded age for
those who appear to be
self-made rare success stories like bill
gates and mark zuckerberg and whitney
wolf heard
foster a false sense of accessibility
suggesting that all of us
if properly motivated can climb up a
social ladder
that almost ubiquitously functions as a
down escalator
of course as the events of game styling
have shown people still
do dislike or at least distrust
billionaires
like a lot possibly as much as the folks
throwing eggs that the aster opera house
did
but perhaps the illustrious reddit
inspired stock market debacle kind of
explains the
change that's happened rather than
questioning the rules of the game that
the very very wealthier plane like
workers during the gilded age did
we're mostly just eager for a piece of
the action which is why i'm still
all in on amc hold on it's my hedge fund
manager
that failed too
but anyway what do you guys think are
billionaires
awesome philanthropists with great baby
name ideas or are they a pasty-faced
menace to society
let us know in the comments big thanks
to all our patrons for your support
hit that subscribe button like a
pinkerton agent knocking out a peaceful
steel worker
and don't forget to ring that bell and
as always thanks for watching
[Music]
later
oh
are you okay